j'ai 9 ans j'ai 9 ans et vous hais la
suisse au bord de la seine j'ai 9 ans
est à l'heure j'étais derrière la régie
là bas avec le sonorisateur on est en
été 1976 il fait super bon on à
moncontour et un festival et mon père et
travaille au comité des fêtes
c'est lui qui l'organisent c'est super
tout ce qu'ils font je comprends rien à
ce qu'ils font mais c'est super bonjour
moi je le ferai aussi quand je serai
grand je le ferai mon métier
ses animateurs socioculturels mon métier
c'est un animateur d'organiser un
organisateur d'événements sociaux
culturels
mon métier c'est donner du sens c'est
donner la vie c'est produire de
l'intelligence sur un territoire
permettre aux gens de se rapproprier son
territoire là je vous présente ahmed
vous en parlerai plus vraiment tout à
l'heure à m c'est un jeune algérien en
fait qui est l'enfant d'un chef de tribu
touareg qui a parti de participer à un
projet avec moi en 2001 quand je
travaillais pour le conseil général des
côtes d'armor dont l'objectif était
d'organiser une manifestation qui
permettent de prendre à la fois de
promotionner la politique internationale
du conseil général est de permettre à
des jeunes costarmoricains de rencontrer
des jeunes ligériens tunisien bosniaque
niamien belge voilà dans le cadre d'une
action à saint brieuc et là où souvent
les collectivités ont tendance à avoir
une méthodologie totalement descendante
en arrivant avec un budget relativement
conséquents sur un territoire et en
proposant une action
on a cherché à inverser le processus en
disant voilà pourquoi ne pas proposer
une méthodologie ascendante en fait une
méthodologie de léger ascendant de
consistait à considérer que le
département des côtes d'armor était un
grand territoire certes mais il ne
l'était pas ce qu'il était composé
uniquement de micro territoire qui était
seul garant d'un certain nombre de
compétences de savoir-faire de
particularités voir d'identité
culturelle bien affirmé donc en fait on
a été voir une dizaine de structures sur
les côtes d'armor à qui on a proposé de
porter un micro projets pendant une
quinzaine de jours où chacun d'entre eux
à les accueillir des vietnamiens des
tunisiens
un des costarmoricains des nigériens et
c'est autour de pratiques que ces
structures maîtrise ça pouvait les
musiques traditionnelles les musiques
actuelles l'art du cirque avec la seule
condition c'est tous ces gens se
réunissent en fin de fin de parcours au
bout quinze jours à saint brieuc au parc
des promenades lors d'une grande
manifestation très institutionnel et en
fait ce projet là est assez particulier
puisqu'il a rencontré un succès à double
titre
on a été totalement dépossédé du projet
les gens ont adhéré à mon sens ça a été
la première visite
la seconde c'est que l'effective mans
les projets en donner quelque chose
d'intéressant et la restitution qui a eu
lieu à saint brieuc a accueilli
plusieurs milliers de personnes
on a vu des élus heureux voilà souriant
d'avoir rempli la mission ce qui arrive
des fois et la question qu'on s'est
posée mais c'est en quoi ce projet a été
une réussite
est-ce que c'était ces quinze jours de
micro projets dont on avait été
totalement déposséder quasi consciemment
ou est ce que c'était ces deux jours de
manifestations à saint brieuc où est-ce
que c'était en fait le chemin qu'ils
n'avaient pas permis d'aboutir de l'un à
l'autre
en fait en tous les cas ce qu'ont à la
retirer de cette manifestation comme
enseignement c'est que dynamiser un
territoire c'est d'abord reconnaître les
acteurs et la population qui le
composent alors quand je dis ça c'est en
même temps avaient un message que
j'envoie des élus parce que je sais
qu'il ya des élus dans la salle et que
la priorité allait peut-être là et c'est
ça qui avait fonctionné dans ce projet
et à m dont je vous ai parlé tout à
l'heure c'est moi un peu d'émotion
chaque fois aux gendarmes maîtres dont
je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure qui
était un petit enfant dans ses bras qui
d'ailleurs dans la salle qui a 15 ans
maintenant
ahmed il est pas rentrer au pays en fait
il est tombé malade et en fait il a
passé une batterie de tests et en fait
ils allaient tout à fait bien je pense
qu'ils n'avaient pas envie de partir et
donc du coup il est resté dormir à la
maison et en fait pour me remercier
d'avoir été un hôte accueillant
attentionné le jour je vais proposer de
venir à la fête de mon fils le plus
grand la fête de l'école dans un petit
village à briand
à jean mi rural et ben il s'est habillé
de son plus beau costume celui qui le
représentait le mieux sa tribu séparant
les lui-même
je vous laisse imaginer dans un petit
village en milieu rural un touareg qui
débarque
bon ça l'a fait ça l'a fait mais en même
temps c'est vrai qu'ils voient là c'est
ce qui m'a dit tu as été un hôte
attentionné
j'irai de la particularité de ce terme
oat c'est qu'il a un double sens l'autre
c'est à la fois celui qui accueille mais
celui qui est accueilli et en fait son
message c'était de dire que la posture
que vous avez en tant que hôte
c'est à dire quand en accueillant
conditionne la posture que vous avez en
tant qu'hôte en tant qu accueillis on
s'aperçut très tard j'ai mis du temps à
comprendre tout ça est en fait ceci dit
j'aimerais bien vérifier vérifier si
c'est possible de traduire ça dans une
organisation notamment dans
l'organisation d'un festival et quelques
années plus tard je travaille à nouveau
pour le conseil général entre temps on
avait monté là contre mars pour
pérenniser la méthodologie qu'on avait
vus sur le sur le premier projet la
consigne que qu'on avait donné puisque
ce festival est un festival expérimental
comporte avec des jeunes la seule
consigne qu'on avait donné ses il faut
travailler sur cette notion d'hôtes qui
est l'hôtesse que c'est l'organisateur
du festival est ce que c'est le public
etc et on avait construit son projet
autour d'une méthodologie un peu
conceptuel joue là vous c'était
considéré qu'une organisation c'est une
articulation permanente entre 4 qu'alain
le cadre philosophique c'est à dire le
sens vos envies la finalité le cadre
légal c'est-à-dire la loi les normes le
cadre méthodologique c'est à dire la
programmation votre projet l'imagination
à la programmation de votre projet et le
cadre organisationnel c'est à dire la
réalisation même de votre projet est en
fait
à partir de ce travail là de ces
questionnements les jeunes ont
complètement construit leur projet avec
un exemple tout simple vous organiser un
festival à des lieux le plus rentable du
festival c'est pas forcément par
forcément les entrées en voilant
beaucoup de festivals c'est la buvette
malheureusement ou légale et de ceux ci
ça dépend en tous les cas pour mon
exemple il vaut mieux que ça soit la
buvette
si vous levez ouvrir une buvette sur
notre festival quel cadre vous
interrogez en premier le cadre légal
effectivement et c'est tout à fait
logique
vous souhaitez ouvrir une buvette dans
un festival vous envoyer un courrier au
maire au minimum 15 jours avant en
faisant une demande d'autorisation
tempête temporaire de débits de boisson
catégories de vins bières et spiritueux
ce cas là ça va pour autant la question
des jeunes s'étaient posez c'est est-ce
que c'est normal qu'un enfant qui
veulent boire un soda puissent se
retrouver à un moment donné dans un
festival avec un titre qui en avoir des
bières depuis 10h où depuis quelques
heures peut en tous les cas avait dit
avait eu un positionnement ferme en
disant non qu'est-ce que ça
quel est l impact du coup sûr le cadre
méthodologique et organisationnelles et
du coup vous avez décidé d'ouvrir deux
buvettes
une buvette sans alcool avec une
tarification particulière moins cher que
d'alcool une animation particulière et
un peu plus loin ils sont suffisamment
éloignée mais en même temps pas trop
puisque quand vous êtes en groupe d'amis
voilà vous pouvez avoir envie d 2 une
buvette avec alcool avec tarification
spécifique
une animation particulière et c'est donc
on voit bien comment un moment donné en
se positionnant sur le cadre
philosophique ça peut agir son cadre
méthodologique l'organisationnel ils
sont allés beaucoup plus loin sauf hélas
je pense que certains d'entre vous vont
me rejoindre
s'il ya bien une situation anxiogène
dans un festival n'est ce pas mesdames
si à partir du moment où on a envie de
faire pipi c'est un vrai problème c'est
un cauchemar en fait souvent les
toilettes sont très loin mal éclairé
sale mal fréquentée ça je sais pas mais
en tous les cas voilà c'est toujours une
situation anxiogène
partant de ce principe les jeunes ont
fait le choix de travailler avec un
collectif de plasticiens
ce qui permet vous pressentez monic la
mouche en fait
monique ce sont des toilettes en fait
vous avez sur le toit un dj à
l'intérieur vous avez cinq six toilettes
qui sont design et par des plasticiens
vous avez un tapis rouge avec des
escaliers comme à cannes et vous avez au
pied de monique un bar est-ce que bien
parce que du coup on fait le site
mais vous avez surtout dans ce bar des
gens qui fabriquent des taxes des tartes
salées sucrées dont l'odeur retourne
dans les toilettes les toilettes sont
déployés toutes les 10 minutes donc on
parle d'une situation hyper anxiogène a
du coup une situation où là ça devient
un lieu d'animation un lieu d'échangé tu
sais quand on a évalué ce projet là ce
qui est vraiment ressorti en fait c'est
cette notion de bienvenue les gens nous
ont dit on s'est sentis bienvenus donc
on a pu vérifier effectivement que la
posture de l'hôte agit réellement et que
l'action se caractérise par le sens
qu'on me donne quelques années plus tard
j'ai eu la chance de travailler sur un
projet qui s'appelait le cube l'idée
c'était de construire une salle éphémère
sur laquelle ont projetée à l'extérieur
ce qui se passe à l'intérieur
et donc pour ce faire on a monté un
chantier école autour d'un triptyque
culture insertion et bâtiments trois
secteurs d'activité qui n'ont pas qui
ont peu ou prou l'habitude de travailler
ensemble
en tous les cas pas souvent on a monté
un chantier école de deux mois durant
lesquels on a formé dizaine de
stagiaires éloignés de l'emploi par
manque de qualification en leur
proposant de passer des diplômes façon
de travail en hauteur des permis pour
pouvoir lever des charges etc
on a fait intervenir un coach sportif
que vous voyez sur l'écran tous les
matins tous les soirs
voilà et ça a donné le club donc en fait
deux mois de chantier école pour un
week-end d'exploitation
je laisse prendre la mesure à quel point
à un moment donné notre projet culturel
n'a pris qu'une place un film dans le
projet général et a su abandonner des
choses et ça a donné une soirée électro
extraordinaire où il ya eu sept mille
neuf cents personnes je crois
l'enseignement nous a donné le cubain
c'est que produire de l'intelligence
collective c'est d'abord
un écosystème culture insertion bâtiment
est un écosystème auquel on donne du
sens parce que j'ai oublié de vous dire
c'est que sur les dix stagiaires
je vais prendre l'exemple d'un stagiaire
qu'on appelait le belge puisqu'il était
belle geof lui il est venu me voir en me
disant c'est ma dernière chance
après ça pour moi c'est terminé je les
ai f je toxicomanes mes beaux parents ne
veulent pas m'accueillir etc
ça a été le premier type embauché suite
au projet par un nos partenaires en cdi
il a eu sa petite maison il a acheté sa
voiture sa femme nuls rejoint ils ont eu
un enfant voilà c'est un exemple parmi
tant d'autres mais en tous les cas
l'écosystème qu'on avait créé avait
permis de trouver du sens alors je
compare souvent les projets les actions
à un entonnoir
vous comprendrez assiégé manque si vous
réduisez la partie haute de l'entonnoir
vous allez aller très rapidement
résultats n'y a pas de problème puisque
vous transformez l'entonnoir en tuyaux
mais vous allez passer à côté du sens or
si vous élargissez la partie haute de
l'entonnoir il ya très fortes chances
que vous allez aggloméré autour de vous
des partenaires des gens qui croient en
votre projet voilà vous allez expliquer
le sens et vous avez rassemblé autour de
vous en fait qui est ce qui est
compliqué dans une organisation c'est
patent de de produire un programme ou
une action parce que pour ça il faut des
compétences savoir faire à la technicité
ce qui est compliqué dans une
organisation c'est produire du sens
parce que le sens sa demande de
l'abandon sa demande du partage sa
demande de l'empathie c'était compliqué
lance dans une organisation c'est pas
que chacun soit à sa place c'est que
chacun trouve sa place
moi mon métier l'animateur en fait c'est
de me faire déposséder du projet vont
pas pour me débarrasser de quelque chose
je payais pour en même temps ça m'a de
faire le travail mais pour être sûr que
les gens qui travaillent avec moi
trouveront leur place en projet les
réaliserons par le projet et enfin
l'organisation pour moi doit être
abordée par le sens et non pas par le
contrôle ou le pilotage mais bien par
l'adhésion
c'est bien je fais rire le public sans
le vouloir
parce qu'elle n'est ce pas n'est ce pas
l'essence même d'une association que
d'avoir de l'adhésion j'ai 48 ans est le
chemin ben je suis tu je suis sur le
chemin et chaque jour ce chemin me
permet des rencontres tout aussi
impromptue intéressantes les unes que
les autres et je fais souvent aussi le
parallèle entre mon métier et le
compagnonnage le compagnonnage en fait
c'est quoi ces des rencontres celle
échanges de savoir faire
c'est l'amour du geste juste le
compagnon il ya une chose qu'il sait
quand il commence son périple sait qu'il
va devoir faire une oeuvre ça il le sait
au départ les seuls le chemin lui permet
de comprendre pourquoi il doit faire
cette oeuvre
et je terminerai par une phrase de
michel maffesoli qui dit là deux sens
c'est à dire de signification que ce qui
a du sens c'est à dire une finalité
merci merci de votre attention